thank you for joining us a number of
coronavirus cases reported
in india since the start of the pandemic
has exceeded
20 million it came as the health
ministry announced more than 300 000
infections for the 13
straight day and with nearly 3 500
deaths in the last 24 hours
the number of fatalities has topped 220
000.
the surge in cases has brought hospitals
close to collapse
on monday 24 patients died after yet
another health facility
ran out of oxygen let's speak to our
india correspondent
elizabeth who joins us live from new
delhi so
india passing 20 million cases liz but
the government saying infection rates
are slowing down
that's right folly we heard from the
health minister on monday the health
ministry rather
and they were talking about how cases in
some of the worst affected places
maharashtra has been the worst affected
throughout this pandemic over the past
year
but also in delhi and chhattisgarh that
they are
beginning to see that cases are starting
to plateau there but the problem is
that india is still not conducting
enough tests to know the real
number of infections that's been the
story in india again throughout the
pandemic
but even just more recently testing has
dropped and so
we can't take the numbers to be
exactly as they are the health ministry
also said
that as well as cases maybe beginning to
plateau in these states that they are
going up in at least
10 states including the poorest bihar
which has some of the worst healthcare
infrastructure
in the country and only one doctor for
every
28 000 patients they also spoke about
the situation with the oxygen in the
country and
reiterated that there is no oxygen
shortage but again if you look at what
the government is doing the health
ministry spokespeople were saying that
but the government is still doing
everything it can now to bring as much
oxygen into the country
and transport it using planes using the
indian air force using trains because
as we've been reporting people are
continuing to lose their lives from
oxygen shortages and more criticism liz
is being levelled at the government
that's right foley the government is
going ahead with a
huge project to rebuild one of india's
most iconic
areas which also has the indian
parliament building
which was built by the british in the
1930s it was announced on monday
that the project which is going to cost
more than two billion dollars and
include a new home for the prime
minister
that the prime minister's new residence
will be completed by the end of next
year now despite there being a very
strict lockdown in delhi where only
essential services are allowed and
construction is only allowed if workers
live on the premises
uh workers are being bussed in to dig up
central new delhi and critics of the
project of whom there are many
say that environmental clearances for
this were rushed through without proper
consultation
but perhaps more importantly that this
is an area
that doesn't need to be rebuilt that
attracts many international tourists but
also
local residents who go and spend time
there and that
um it shouldn't that this shouldn't be
going ahead
went at a time when the economy is doing
so poorly because of the pandemic over
the past year
elizabeth thank you very much for that
elizabeth branham is our correspondent
in new delhi